I'm talking to mr.
Charles brown who worked
in the lights workshop as
a an apprentice boiler mirka during the
time of the building of the bridge. And he
remember getting the job in the first
place. Mr bloom. Yes. Are you started as an
apprentice boilermaker and feb.
Two 1927. Actually my father
was instrumental in obtaining
the job for me he was
anxious that i should have
a trade. And made enquiries and
lined the job up for me i can
still clearly remember my first day
starting in the light shop in the
marking off section. I was only
a little black i wore short pants and was
after been taken into the workshop.
The charge handed joe barton. Took me
up to another apprentice whose
name was charlie nunn and i
started with charlie who went to
a great deal of trouble explaining the job
itself for the tools to be used and all
that sort of thing. It was very helpful.
I was only fifteen at the time and
then after
a while of course. Working with charlie
nano i then brainstorm on my own
under the guidance of joe
barton. Mainly and later. Had
an assistant of my own in the marking off
in that shop. Can you explain how you
went about marking off. Well yes
the all the marking i'm sorry.
Most of the marking was done by means of
templates that the templates came from
the loft on top of the
workshop. The job or sections
were laid out on the floor and
templates were taken from the
drawings or the laying out on the
floor. They were then sent down to the.
Marking section and they were
used in the marking we had
a great deal of accuracy was
necessary in the marking and marking
through the template in
the holes was by means of
a tit punch. Then they
were lined up by means of
a steel scriber which had
a very thin line. Work was to
a thirty second of an inch.
And after the. Punching
through the template they were there no end
up with the bigger punch to locate the
holes for the drilling. And do you mean
in the marking up over the whole of the
time. Practically the
whole of the time. What's
the end of my apprenticeship.
I know that i cut a hell of
a lot of those little lattice
work that you may see on the
sides of the road on the footpath and was
a fairly monotonous job. Then again i cut
a lot of those light standards or the
plate for the light standard by means of
oxyacetylene. Apart from those
two i was in the marking section
were all the time. Do you remember the
process right from the start of the light
workshops through to the heavy could you
describe it for us. Yeah well. Perhaps if
i could go back even further than that all
the steel used to come by ship and the
silicon steel as you know came from england.
Other sections came from new castle b
h p. They were landed on the
wharf from the. From the ship's
plates then moved down to go through
a main goals any plates that were distorted
or bent or buckled or went through
there for straightening any of the
other sections that angle line or r
e j is. Went through
a angelo and straighten up who straightened
those they then went over into the
bottom by of the shop. The angle to
be cut to approximate sizes in the
angle cropper the plate
and moved over to be
marked and cut to size in the
guillotines they were those very
big guillotines that cut plate
eight feet wide by up to two and
a quarter inches thickness. How they're
from there they were cut to approximate
sizes and they moved up then into the
marking section. They were marked for
location of holds. They then
moved up to the drills who were
in the line in the next sequence was the
drills. They were drilled and then further
up into the light shop was the light
assembly. They were painted with the
red led and bolted together the
different sections bolted together
and then they moved further
along that shop then up to the
riveting where they were reported
from there. That was all the
light fabrications. Then they
went up into the heavy shop where lots
of them were joined together to make the
huge girders and various
sections chords etc.
That finally were taken by pont out to
underneath their location in the harbor
under the bridge. It was the first
riveting session was done by hotel x.
Wasn't it. Yes it. Yes they were
they were huge horseshoe shaped
hydraulic riveting machines.
The river. Were cooked
heated in oil fired furnaces. They were
in quite hot they were right doubt of
that and thrown by the rivet heater to
another to the catcher. He caught them
in half. Kara scene ten he pulled
a mount put i'm in
a hole the. Old or up then knocked
them in and engaged the dolly
and of the riveting machine and the boilermaker
on the other side of course operate
at the machine to complete the riveting and
of course when they were done up in the
that was would take one angle so to speak
when they got to put the two sections
together in the form of
a box and they needed to to use pneumatic
remitting that's right. Yes that's so
then when they have been.
Fabricated or assembled into
a box girders it was impossible
to use the horseshoe hydraulic
machines and the riveting and then was
done by hand. There any incidents
particularly that you remember in the
workshops where you work. Just let me correct
the statement i just made there about
riveting by hand hand riveting would give the
impression to those who are knowledgeable
in the trade of using the old hammer.
At the course i didn't mean this i meant
by use of the riveting gun and not the old
hand riveting that used to be done in the
shipyards hamming them down. Sorry what.
Do you remember any of it's
a dense particularly you that you while
you were in the workshop to embody
accidents in the first
place. Yes there were
a couple of accidents that did occur and.
One i remember the one of
the at one time. The dogman
were carrying
a very big. All long lengths
of angle lined to be fixed
onto the rear. Drilling
machines and. Somehow
or other it slipped from the just
as they were locating it on the
stands it slipped off
there and hit one of the
other dogman and broke a couple of
legs and it was in a bad way for
a while. I also remember that
incident of the driller. Who
was bending over the plate
that he was drilling to do
something or other off
a get exactly what it was at the drill it
was still running caught in his overalls
and it. twelve him around and around quite
a few times before they were able
to stop the drill there were
other accidents. You know
something like that of
a similar nature but i think they were
the main ones that i was able to see. To
remember any amusing incidents in their
workshops do you. Yes we had our moments
there at times you know they were pretty
hard times and but there were some good
times. I used to be
a big. American bloke we used to call the
yank and he worked on those mean girls
that were out at the end of the wharf
and at he used to fancy himself as
a flamethrower and. When things got
a bit slack. He like to
entertain fellow workers by
taking a mouthful of camera scene
and then spreading it out and onto
a match and
a great line of flame coming
resulting from his actions.
The other one that sticks in my mind is
it. And i had an ironworker assisting me
and his name was bluey white haired
blue we proclaimed himself to be
a very tough guy and
a very strong man. And he
used to get bags of rivets
and to lift them from the floor in his
teeth. You were used to make beds of
nails for him to lie on.
And there is to get
a board with the nails and need braces
shoulders in these arms and he'd say hit me
on the back and so we'd give him
a whack with them need say oh that's
the stuff and i'd enjoy it. At times
we'd go up outside the wharf there was
escalators and we'd go up to the top
of the street at milton's point. And he
did engage in the pastime of pulling cars
around in his teeth while all of the
successful exploits seemed to encouraging
encourage him and he wanted to go to
greater heights and he thought i'd be
a marvellous thing. If he and
i were to join together in.
Another exploit and what he proposed to do
was to go to the top of the arch at the
top chord. He was going to hang by his
legs from the top chord holding me in his
teeth. Our was see thought
but that was a hell of
a good idea. I wasn't too keen on it myself
and i think that's about where we fell
out and the end of his exploits with
me. Do you remember the lunchers do
use to go on in the workshops then.
Oh yes in the in the lunch hours.
We only had are half an hour but it is
amazing how much you could fit into half an
hour. At times. Some of the boys
myself charlie nunn jack crew and
a couple of the others would get out onto
the wharf in the very hot weather and
we'd dive into off the wharf into the
harbour. These to warn us that there was
a few sharks around but been so young and
a bit more daring than we are now didn't
seem to worry us all that much. Again
there was
a couple of crown and anchor boards always
going there and you know always have
european ease. For if you had more money
threepence is on the boards. They
filled in the lunch hours. How did
you get to work and earn home again. Where
do you live then i live to draw my in at
that time and we used to travel
from draw my own to circular quay.
The fare from demy in then was four
pins each way. And the trip over two
from circular quay to milton's
point was twopence that made
a total of sixpence each way. A shilling
a day due to cost us for fares.
There were unfortunate times when
i was a bit indiscreet and
a very good friend of mine at that time
and other apprentice was harold altgens.
And he lived out around the forest lodge
and we used to go around that way
sometimes through wide bay to draw mine.
And there were times when we put our
pennies on the crown and
anchor board hoping to win
a fortune. Instead of that we lost our
fare home. And that who we'd had our block
of tickets for the fairy. Get across to the
quay or ride but from there on we used
to have to scale the trams. All the way
home. As dodging the conductors. That's
right. Yes you dodged the conductor you
get on the wrong side of the tram the
opposite side of the tram to where the
conductor is or down the back in the rear
driving compartment. And sometimes
you'd have to change trams
a couple of times but we generally
made it. How much did you get paid to
murders do you remember. Yes i do very
clearly. When i first started in my first
year the wage rate was eighteen shillings
a week in my second year it went up to
twenty four. Bob third year was thirty two
and six the for the year was.
Forty five shillings and
in my final year it was £3
£3 but week in my last year. I
had my last all i still have my
last pay envelope. It was dated
the 23rd of the eight thirty
one. And it shows that instead of
receiving the £3. I was paid to
pounce eighteen and threepence now
that's one and nine and short and the
reason for this must be in that i was late.
One morning. Now. Can anyone to
vera lawson owe a woman
a girl who was vera lawson
then. Who was in the office
and at times she used to help with the
time sheet and making up of the pages
and recently after all this time fifty
years i had the great pleasure of meeting
her again. And i reminded her that i
was one and ninepence short in my
last pay more than fifty years ago and
sought an explanation from she said well
charlie you must have been late. I said
well i can't recall it. You said you might
differ gotten it. But i said look i've
been worrying about this for fifty years
where my one and nine months went to she
said well stop worrying. Here's you too.
Bob. Now that makes
a square. 200 immerse become
permanent. Yes yes well i
were thruppence and i've got this for
a prince and the next time i meet i'm
going to give it to us. That'll be at the
reunion and rodeos. Yes that's
so yes. Well i think we're past
a certain moments now you remember when
you were relieved of. High do as i say i
finished late in 1931 all of these deal
work. On the bridge had been
completed. And it was necessary to
reduce staff. In those days
there was no week's notice. I
remember clearly some of the men went door
in the weeks preceding myself going off
and we used to finish at five o'clock at
those times about four o'clock alf market
. Who was the foreman would
come down. And when he
came down into the bays about that time
everybody would be looking at him with.
Great apprehension. And he
would go up to a man and it's
a your name is joe smith
yes. You have finished
a night and that was the unceremonious
way in which you were told that you were
finished as i say no weeks notice just
about an hour or less notice and that was
the end of it. But it took you back to
the some of the other conditions in the
workshops we haven't to cover it. Do you
remember what the working conditions were
like in there yes well fifty years ago
there were none of the conditions that we
have today. The shop itself was of
a dirt floor. Had to be hosed down twice
a day to keep the dust down
there was no washing facilities
. If you want to do
a wash. Before you went home. You're
washed under the tap the same
tap that was used to attach the hose to
hose the floor down. There were not even
bubblers drinking bubblers
in the shop. You got
a drink from the same tap. There was no
dressing rooms there was not even anywhere
to hang your clothes in. You had to find
some spot the corner of an angle iron or
some part of the structure. To hang
your coat. And. And generally there was
no as i said before there was no weeks.
Or each notice on dismissal there was no
sickly. Compensation was not paid
until after three days. If you're on
or off on compo for less than three days
you didn't get anything. It was about two
thirds of pure weekly wages
then during member of
a union activity in the
shops or yes yes that was
a great part of it. It was in this way
a very closely. Net
well-organized job to be on.
And there was i remember
the and i felt the
my chip the comradeship that
existed in the shop. I was only
a small boy but some of the men
took me under their wing and
you know gave me
a great deal of support in my job
there. The when the meetings were held
they were conducted out on the wharf. Near
where the angle smith worked and he had
a block that he worked on and this was the
platform on which the chairman of the
meeting and others addressed the
meeting the chairman was the
the blacksmith in the on the job so far
as i can remember there was only the one
blacksmith there and he was
a big irishman called rared and he
looking back i used to remind me of the
power and we learnt at school of the the
village blacksmith with you know
great muscles and that he was
a very very competent. Chairman
he kept the meeting under
controlled and
a well disciplined meeting that was the
result and decisions were made without
wasting too much time at all. Do you member
anybody else. Speaking at the meetings
we've got
a particular yes i can one man
that sticks in my mind is the.
He was the secretary of the ironworkers
union then colon tannic. And colin was
a scotchman who still had
the. Scotch very very strong
got accent. He was
a very vigorous speaker and between
him and reardon. It resulted
in very informative
well-conducted meetings to us apprentices
who shouldn't have been there
because we were not affected by decisions
of the meeting or what was going on. We
always took up the front positions
at the meeting and thoroughly
enjoyed this addresses to the
meeting by these two men.
That were there are many
strokes were. There were
a few ideas by comparison
the day they were just
a few not many at all but
it will realize that
they were bad times and
the job. Was becoming
more dangerous as it progressed
and it was necessary to
maintain. And if possible improve the
wages and conditions that existed
and it was necessary at times for
a stoppage. I think i only have about
one day's duration. There wasn't any
lengthy stoppages at all. Who
is the records agree with you.
Do you do you remember what happened to
you after you finished up on the bridge
where were you for instance when the bridge
was opened. Well nineteen end of 1931
was in the depths of the depression. I
finished up there with my last week's pay.
I think also that because i was about three
months short of the five years that i
was in danger to i got as i
remember about fifty pounds.
That's what i had my father was
unemployed. He'd been thrown out of
employment. He was
a victim of the depression
at that time and i being
a fully fledged tradesman
then full of hope went around
a few of the steel fabrication shops at
the time i remember going to sydney steel
looking for
a job and i chased me out of the bloody
place. There was enough. And no hope at all
. Of getting a job rather than
a stop home under the conditions that
existed then. I took to the bush.
My first stop was all
brief from there with
a cousin of mine. We travelled through
the victoria and other parts carrier now
swag and in fact on the day that the
bridge was open the 19th of march
1932. I was camped under another much
smaller bridge. It was the bridge over the
campeche be reverse at elmore in victoria.
No glory for you on the opening
day no none at all as i say i finished
up on the bridge without too much fuss
without too much glory with
a great future behind me and the
wide open road in front of me.
Do you remember what you've got
for the dole in those days. Yes.
Victoria was
a better place for. Collecting
the dial and in new south wales.
Because if you kept travelling and
went through it from town to town
. You could collect the dole in each
town it amounted to about six shillings.
I'm not sure but i think in new south wales.
Well i'm sure that in new south wales
it was only once per week. No matter
where you were whether you're in
a different town or not because there was
a brick lane day on which you only you
could collect the dole. It was in
the form of
a voucher that you took this voucher
to the shops or the store. And you
in return. You've got your tea and your
sugar and braid and all that sort of thing
i can remember as
a matter of fact the first time i
attempted to get the dole was in all brie
and you had to sort of establish yourself
once you were on it. Your all right. But
getting on it was pretty tough. And at the
old ripley's station who were in charge
of issuing these vouchers. There was
a great line of men waiting for it. I
got in the line. And when it came to
my turn. There was a massive big sigh
a gent sitting at the desk. And he said
yes. As if he didn't know what i was there
for. And i said and i could have
a bowl about you please. Without even looking
up he said where do you come from. I
said i come from sydney. So it was
a try in leaving the station up there at
three o'clock this afternoon be on it and
i said what about me doubts aj and he said
get out so i bloody well got out but i
didn't go away. I got on the end of the
queue again. And when it came to me turned
again he'd forgotten all about
that and i establish myself as
a recipient of the dole. Yes. Did
you get any other work in the
in all brew during the time the yes.
Well when we were travelling around
the country. We were constantly
looking for bits of casual work fruit
picking in various areas
and great picking.
Farm work in the harvesting
season. It was. High to be cut
and carted in there was. To be harvested
bags so in carting into the silos
and wherever it was available. We got this
job temporary as it was but it kept us
going. And all brie in
those days there was
a break of the gauge and goods fruit
etc from or going into new south wales
had to be trained shipped there.